Godzilla Vs. Kong is finally out in
the world, and while most people are
paying attention to the eponymous Titans, the
film has more than just these two Monsters.
Here are five characters from the film who
are more important than you probably realize.
In the last few years, podcasts and podcasters
have increasingly grown in popularity, and as the
volume of podcasts increases, so, too, does the
number of podcasters becoming household names.
It seems safe to say that by the end
of Godzilla vs. Kong, Bernie Hayes,
played by Brian Tyree Henry, is about to become
the most famous podcaster in the world of kaiju.
By the time we're introduced to Bernie,
he's already dedicated several hundred
episodes worth of podcast time to exploring the
conspiracies behind Monarch and giant monsters.
If Bernie's podcast was popular before the events
of Godzilla vs Kong, then imagine how popular he
will be after playing an active role in helping
the two monsters defeat Mechagodzilla — and
imagine how informed the public at large
will be about Monarch and their shenanigans.
And while we're on the subject
of Monarch's giant robots...
There aren't exactly villains in Godzilla vs. Kong
so much as there are antagonists who
think they're doing something smart,
only to wind up hoisted by their own
egomania. Ren Serizawa , played by Shun Oguri,
is one-half of a duo of bad guys whose belief
is very simple: in order for humanity to thrive,
they must prove themselves to be a stronger,
collective apex predator than any giant monster.
The creation of Mechagodzilla using the combined
might of King Ghidorah's brain and the human mind
may have failed, but that doesn't mean it will
be the last effort made toward a similar end. And
while Ren seems pretty dead by the end of Godzilla
vs. Kong, that doesn't mean his story is over.
We could always see a prequel story explaining
how Ren came to create Mechagodzilla. Ren is,
after all, the son of Ken
Watanabe's Ishirō Serizawa,
who was much more of the opinion
that humanity should play its part
in the world by sometimes standing back
and letting the giant monsters fight.
"Let them fight."
What caused Ren to employ a
decidedly opposing tactic?
Not to restate things, but Godzilla vs. Kong is
primarily focused on the stories of two
giant monsters. However, Nathan Lind,
played by Alexander Skarsgård, has a backstory
way too important not to flesh out later.
When Lind is approached by Walter Simmons
about his potential involvement in traveling
to the center of Hollow Earth, we get a
very brief mention of his past attempt.
What we know is that Lind's brother died in
an attempt to get the kaiju stomping grounds,
but we don't really know how that happened. We
don't know why Lind is fixated on Hollow Earth,
we don't know how he became affiliated
with Monarch, and we didn't see him fall
out with the organization either. That
story is at least worth a tie-in comic.
But much like Ren, the other reason why Lind is so
important is that it's his ideas that helped drive
the journey to Hollow Earth in the first place.
It seems likely that Lind will play an important
role in understanding, and even benefiting
from, Hollow Earth in forthcoming stories.
Ilene Andrews, played by Rebecca Hall is
the reason King Kong stays safe for as long
as he does — she is his guardian in many
ways. The containment area Kong calls home
exists in part because of Andrews,
and the safeguards used to keep Kong
safe as he travels to Hollow Earth
are a result of her care as well.
When we see Hollow Earth, one of the things
we notice straight away is that there
is even more monster life down there.
And if there's anyone who can catalog and
understand that life, it's Ilene Andrews.
Andrews is important for the future of this
franchise precisely because she'll likely
stand opposed to the "destroy all monsters"
edict of the antagonists. And if she takes
on more power at Monarch in the wake of this
story, any attempts to build mechs will likely
be tempered by Andrews' level head and respect
for all of nature's creatures, including Kong.
All that being said, there is
one character in Godzilla vs.
Kong who stands head and shoulders
above the entire rest of the cast:
Jia, played by Kaylee Hottle. To say that
Jia's empathy and ability to communicate
with Kong literally saved all of humanity's
collective bacon is probably an understatement.
And she's only going to become more important for
humans and monsters alike both as she gets older.
If you recall, in Kong: Skull Island, the island
is home to more than just the big ape — there's
also a tribe of people living symbiotically
with him. And while Kong protects those people,
they also respect and watch out for him.
We find out in Godzilla vs. Kong that the
only surviving member of that tribe is
Jia and it's through her ability to use
sign language that humanity learns Kong isn't
just intelligent but also able to communicate.
Jia is so in tune with Kong that she can feel
his heart slow down to the point of death.
Without her, he wouldn't even be alive right
now. It's hard to say that there's anyone else
who could convince Kong to fight for the
human race at this point other than Jia.
Similarly, we may discover that other monsters
are able to communicate through sign language.
As she gets older, it seems likely
that Jia may not only be the person
best able to understand these creatures;
she may also be their strongest advocate.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your
favorite movie moments are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.